angle thank you welcome back to those of
you who are joining us on the live
stream this is actually a workshop of
council uh no decisions are being made
and but it is a chance to us to be
informed and we thought uh it would be
nice to share uh the information that
we're receiving uh publicly Michael do
you want to introduce the workshop
yes thank you we're going to have a
discussion uh presented to us from
infometrics so we have Brad Olson and
Nick binston who will both be giving us
a small presentation on what the
report what is in in the report in
relation to the effects of the
economics on invercargill City so I look
forward to hearing it myself I have read
the report obviously but um it's always
good to hear it firsthand from those who
have prepared it so I will hand over to
Brad into the chair
thanks uh Michael welcome Brad welcome
Nick we we're really in your hands
fantastic Nick um I think you're you'll
drive the first bit
yep uh we'll just get my screen sharing
set up
remember the technology we didn't try
out because it looks like it's going to
work
how's that everyone see the um the
slides
yes
fantastic all right um thanks for the
introduction Michael
um so we produce this report for
um invercargill City earlier in the year
um I guess to sort of squeak it in in
time to sort of inform some of the
Indian plan
um deliberations I guess thinking that
was going on but also for theater belong
to him playing so we're sort of looking
out over the next um over the
particularly over the next 10-year plan
cycle
um the thing will take around about half
an hour to run through the presentation
um and then um leaves about 15 minutes
for a good discussion at the end of your
questions as well so um we've covered a
few different topics but we'll come back
to them all in in the discussion at the
end
uh in terms of what we're going to cover
um I'll cover the demographic
projections first um looking at our
projection of population and households
invercargill and sort of play something
we've got a national context in terms of
what's happening with net migration
then I'll hand over to Brad he'll go
through inflation inflation in the in
the general sense um and particularly um
how how it's affecting um local
government costs
um and as well as costs um sort of house
household consumer inflation as well in
terms of what that might mean for um I
guess writing affordability as well and
then we'll jump back to myself
um to go through our economic forecast
which is looking at over the longer term
looking at employment industries that
are driving employment and then a couple
of Industries key industry assumptions
that the council was interested in the
staff are interested in rather around Ty
and international students
foreign
what's going on and then move through to
um to what we're seeing uh or what we're
expecting from the cargo specifically
so at the national level um we've come
off of here a pretty amazing period for
net migration
um probably a combination of a
relatively loose set of immigration
policies and the sort of proverbial rock
star economy through the 2010s and so we
saw a higher and longer peak of
international net migration in that
period and that thought we're right
through the country
oh it's fairly unanticipated at the time
stats and said expected um around about
22 000 um net migration through this
period so I was sort of expecting it to
kind of stop about here
um and then they sort of revised that
when it started going up just sort of 26
000 so sort of something about sort of
here if you can see my cursor
um uh and then sort of trend they're
expecting the trend back down to sort of
the 15 000 level
um obviously
um transpired somewhat different
um even our forecasts have changed over
time
um so when we wrote this report for
invercargill um earlier in the year
we're expecting the Green Path to occur
um and that was the rationale there was
that we're expecting uh migration to
sort of catch up and resume once um our
border restrictions close one actually
lost sort of miq and those sorts of um
those sorts of handbrakes if you will um
but what the actual historic data
started changing and before the borders
opened we started to see quite a sharp
outflow of people
um which I think reflects that people
that wanted to go overseas once they
could sort of sort of see the end of miq
thought okay now's a good time to head
off and so we're actually sitting at
around about a 9 000 migration loss at
the moment and we're expecting that to
persist for about three years like 21 22
and 23. um and so obviously the area
between the green and the blue is fairly
different so that means that the
near-term Outlook is probably going to
transpire a little bit differently
also worth noting just before I jump
through
um the outflows are experience at the
moment our net losses um we're
predominantly 20 to 30 year olds so
there's a bit of an OE story to their
story going on there and that's okay you
know we know that kiwi is going there
always and come home but we're actually
seeing and people going to Australia
which is generally less of an OE
destination we're also seeing under tens
um a net loss of under 10 year olds as
well that's not an OE story that's
families going overseas
um it's a better cost of living for for
to get ahead so some of that is probably
a really it is a permanent migration
rather than just the temporary and we
might catch them back later
the other thing to touch on is how
migration is being shared around the
country not just the number of migrants
coming into the country about how
they're getting around and if we look
back to what happened in the 2000s the
last time or the previous time when we
had a large amount of net migration it
pretty much it went to Auckland it
didn't make it very very far beyond that
and so if we look at how Metro councils
took the migration they took the the
lines here 86 went to the Metro areas
um in a fairly small small scraps going
to the blue areas provincial councils
like yourselves and Rural councils like
the South London and Gore neighbors this
really changed as we came into the 2000
into the 2010s rather you see that you
know the blue areas provincial councils
like yourself getting a much greater
share and only 57 of net migration went
to the Metros now that seems to be um
that pattern is quite a fundamental
shift in terms of the way it spreads
around the country and it seems to be
sticking there's a combination of
factors driving that we saw that you
know the metro area started running out
of room started being able to
accommodate that population growth they
became more expensive we had a housing
affordability challenges and also along
the way bumbling along the background
we've also seen the rollout of ultra
fast broadband and and certainly in the
last couple of years we've seen
widespread adoption and work from home
practices which really shifts the shifts
the table much more in the in the in the
provincial areas favor
so going forward we expect something of
this passion to persist with
invercargill and other provincial areas
getting a decent sheet of the migration
flows
moving into invercargill specifically so
I plotted a few different forecasts to
show you how the um how they have
evolved over time
um and unsurprisingly um the stats and
see projections and not not to pick on
them but you know turned up short as As
Time evolved moved on and real data came
through and that reflects that both the
volume immigration into the country and
the distribution was um was UN
unprecedented really
so in 2015 State since he's expected
invercargill would be at 55 200 and 2023
um in 2017 they revised it to 55 900 but
fairly small revision
um and and now in 2021 States and it
revised that sort of 57
um thousand eight hundred um expectation
which sort of puts puts um the city
around here and this actually happened
is we've had a couple of years of
negative so that's sort of showing what
the what the um the dashed orange line
is and so the city will probably be at
something around like around about sort
of 57 000. so well above those those
early
um these two projections which are from
last decade
but also not too far off the forecast
track both of ours and of stats and Z
over the next decade so
um our forecast that we developed
earlier in the year was expecting a
population of 60 500 and invercargill
um by 2034 so the end of your
um uh you know next long-term plan
Horizon
um but given that we've had a couple of
years of decline here and we've sort of
had a sort of deepening net migration
loss it probably might fall a little bit
short maybe down to 60 000 rather than
60 500 but the the key takeaway being a
fairly solid uh rate of growth for that
period not quite as fast as you
experienced through here but certainly a
steeper rate of growth than what was
experienced through the
um through the early 2000s and that
reflects that you've got an aging
population you've got a strong economy
and that's going to pull people in in
the need to pull people in to fill jobs
blowing it through to household
projections so um first things first
you've got a declining household size
which is pretty consistent around the
most parts of the country
um it's driven by an Asian population
growing life expectancy
um sort of softer fertility rates and
that's all contributing to smaller house
obviously more I think retired couples
or whatever's living in their houses
alone for longer more couples at younger
ages without children
um and couples that are having children
having fewer children all that
contributes to a slight decline in the
average household size from 2.39 to 2.35
people per household between 2021 and
2034 so that flows through in terms of
the shape and demand for Council
services but it also means that that
contributes to the demand for growth in
houses because if you've got a smaller
household size you need more houses to
accommodate the population
putting that together to our um to a
forecast household growth track
so we're expecting it once we get out of
the sort of tricky period at the moment
um with the population decline or
expecting a solid growth track of around
0.6 per year over the next um over the
next uh the 2022 to 2034 period which
works out to around about 140 new
households per year so 140 new
households um so sort of meet meet the
needs of of us of your house household
becoming smaller and to meet the need of
that growing population
and on top of that you've also got to
account for whatever
um shortfall you might have in houses or
whatever Old Stock you might need to
replace and so on
with that I'll pass through to Brad um
to go through inflation
cool cool uh thanks Nick uh look I mean
inflation remains chief economic concern
across the economy uh it's something
that we uh continue to look at and
certainly one that we're also worried
hasn't shown particularly strong signs
yet of turning around uh if we move to
the next slide you'll see some of the
estimates that we put together earlier
uh this year for Council so the dark
blue line there was the local government
cost index as published by Bill in their
October 2021 update Council asks for an
update and we provided that through in
March which is the orange line where we
substantially revised up what the
expectation for the lgci might look like
uh in terms of the cost pressures that
might be put on councils around the
country to deliver their services
um so so the the blue and the orange
line You'll Find in the report I've
added the green line today which is from
the October 22 2022 update from bill
which you'll see broadly speaking tracks
our expectations uh with a bit more heat
in it which reflects the higher levels
of inflation that we've seen in reality
across the economy but certainly um uh I
guess uh the upgrade that we've seen in
it substantially reflects the Boost in
inflation that's hit the economy uh in
more recent times importantly though if
we move through to the next one you can
see that it wasn't just a one-year thing
that there is uh you know an increase uh
across the board until about 2026-27
relative to the original track that ltp
2021 would have been prepared on and
importantly as well when we look at the
the numbers here it's worthwhile
remembering that all of these cost
pressures are cumulative because there's
no negatives it means that whatever your
uh you know higher cost pressure so
you're 3.6 3.7 percentage Point increase
in 2022 uh that then sticks around
you've got to add an extra two
percentage points more onto it uh
relative to what you thought to get to
the 2023 figure again
um and so what we very much see is
across Council activities uh both you
know locally and across the country
there has been a considerable boost in
those inflationary pressures importantly
uh to us a greater degree in in many
respects than what we've seen actually
in Consumer Price inflation uh because
of the different basket of goods that
Council buyers Council doesn't buy
apples and bananas uh and similar at
eyes you know harder materials and
different components now if we move
along uh just for a moment slightly uh
wider piece that we did as well and then
I won't go on this for too long because
we could get very much bogged down the
weeds here but we took a look at
expectations using a few different
modeling techniques uh to understand
what some of those long-term cost
increases might look like across a few
components that are important to
council's capital expenditure delivery
worthwhile noting that when we did these
we did uh what you see here is a 30-year
average but we have looked at it over a
single year point of time over the next
30 Years and is considerably more heat
in the near term and therefore
relatively slightly less Heat and the
cost escalation over time but
realistically what you do see
particularly that higher cost for the
likes of Transport ways uh roading in
particular then the other broader
sectors reflects higher fuel expectation
uh fuel cost expectations over time
doesn't of course uh account for any
shifts and how we might construct roads
and similar in the future
uh if we go to the next one please Nick
and I guess just some general more
General uh inflation reviews uh that
we're seeing at the moment uh we've seen
that like I say the consumer's price
index what uh households uh will be
facing uh remains at a high level and in
our minds uh inflation is persistent and
pervasive which means that it will stick
around higher for longer and also is
also going to be more difficult uh to
get rid of importantly we've now seen
interest rate increases uh over the last
year plus by The Reserve Bank yet we see
very little uh in the way of actual
response by inflation to those higher
interest rates and importantly uh with a
lack of real uh change and consumer
activity I say that because a year on
from uh from interest rates starting to
be increased we saw that inflation in
September quarter increased 2.2 percent
on a quarterly basis taking the annual
rate at 7.2 annual that 2.2 percent
quarterly increase was the fourth
largest on Recorder News Zealand since
1987 and it shows really a quadrant
grain level of pricing pressure very
much through some of the input costs the
rational invasion of Ukraine you know
supply chain issues and some are low
those are all true but also an intensely
hot economic environment in New Zealand
and a high level of uh wage pressure
that we're also seeing locally all of
that means that we expect further
increases by The Reserve Bank to the
official cash rate and continuing to
lift interest rates to try and limit
economic demand which over time should
soften pricing pressures that does mean
that in a week or two we're expecting
The Reserve Bank to increase the
official cash rate to uh by 75 basis
points and eventually lift it to a peak
of 5.25 percent
three four months ago we were expecting
a peak official cash rate of 3.5 that's
where it is right now uh the fact that
we've not seen inflation turn around yet
means that we must go further we move to
the next one please look uh we'll
highlight I just wanted to highlight
also um some of the regional pressures
that are coming forward and you can see
inflation here over the last year uh by
uh broad sector that stats NZ producers
and you'll note that provincial areas
and the South Island generally are
seeing more cost pressure than other
parts of the country now that's not to
say that Auckland or Wellington are
getting away scot-free but it is saying
that you can see the pressures coming
through there across Canterbury across
the rest of the south island and similar
closer to the National inflation rate
with some of the other large Urban
centers pulling back more part of that
is a reflection of a lot of economic
activity happening across the regions
and also partially reflects the fact
that there is a smaller markets or for
whatever it is materials people anything
that also May means that there's less
room to maneuver and therefore more
price increases coming forward because
competition is intense for those
resources
what's interesting uh if we look at this
this one here as you'll see that we have
been forecasted quite considerably
larger increases uh to cost pressures
the uh orange blocks here are what we
had forecast when we looked at some
slightly more detailed cost pressures uh
in recent times we've started doing this
uh since we've been working and doing
some of the work for the council earlier
this year so it's so this is some work
that has occurred subsequent to March
and uh those increases that we've put
down there quarterly are fairly large
increases anyway uh the actual activity
the actual cost increase which you'll
see there in the dark blue uh was
considerably larger particularly in the
civil construction sort of
infrastructure capex space which really
does goes to go to show that there's
further actually been further
acceleration and the most recent
inflation figures which doesn't give us
give us a lot of expectations uh the
pricing Trends move around
a few more uh if I can um and I guess
just to note that again we're seeing uh
that those prices continue to pick up
these are our general uh building and
capex expectations across the economy uh
not specific to to various Council uh
activities but importantly you'll see
there that we're expecting that uh
General civil activity will increase or
already has increased 14 over the last
year uh we're expecting that it takes
quite a while to even get back below uh
sort of towards that sort of more four
percent rate uh more around 2024 and
again because none of these lines go
negative uh it means that the entire
cost structure is changing because you
will have cumulative cost increases on
some very large cost increases that
we're still seeing at the moment
fuel prices are our next the next area
that are worrying us at the moment of
course it has big uh challenges both in
in terms of an input across a number of
sectors but also for transport generally
diesel prices remaining at elevated
levels particularly as production has
been cut across the world but also as
we're seeing a shift in in demand at the
moment because of how quickly Aviation
activity is coming back there's
competition for heavier uh fuel oil
types including the likes of diesel and
aviation fuel which means that you have
For the First time seen that Diesel's
now 11 cents a liter more expensive than
91 petrol all of that will translate
through into further transport increases
and in terms of costs to move stuff
around and of course that has further
implications for inflation as well on
the shipping front uh there's very
little relief still on the horizon we
had seen the internationally Global
shipping prices had increased by about
to about nine times pre-pandemic levels
at their Peak last year there's some to
come back to only only if you will 2.5
2.7 times pre-pandemic levels when we
look at New Zealand figures though they
never went up quite as much for the
specific travel routes to New Zealand
but they remain quite elevated and
importantly we still don't hear from
people that there's a very easy way to
move stuff in and out of the country and
so we do expect that those supply chain
pressures and costs will remain for a
while yet just very briefly finally uh
important I guess to note that despite
all of the intense cost pressures that
we're seeing at the moment which does
often uh see some people say well look
why don't we try and do more now to
avoid those higher cost pressures in the
future the difficulty at the moment and
and really one of the reasons that doing
more right now is actually likely to
exacerbate further cost pressures but
also mean it's difficult to deliver on
larger capex plans anyway is the
capacity constraints we're seeing in the
sector you can see here other
construction civil activity and it's
generally speaking infrastructure across
the economy and recent quarters has
actually been declining at a time when
we hear from everyone across the country
just how much work there is to do in
fact on average over 2022 so far
infrastructure delivery has been 5.5
below the average scene in the
pre-pandemic 2019 Year and that does
suggest at the moment we're struggling
to struggling to find workers and are
struggling to find materials and
realistically there are some challenging
but important conversations likely to be
had around the prioritization of
projects both in annual plan and
long-term plan settings because at the
moment again there isn't the materials
that isn't the resource to be able to do
everything that often organizations want
to provide and that does mean that that
prioritization means that what does
critically need to get done is first cab
off the rank otherwise there are
difficulties where projects often try to
start and are still through a lack of
ability to deliver
back to eunuch for the economic forecast
element lovely thanks Brad
um so now we'll shift back to to the
economic forecast looking um
specifically at how things are expected
to play out in invercargill
so first things first
um looking at employment in terms of the
number of full jobs across and the cargo
and compared to um to the rest of the
South and region South London and Gore
District
um the the two areas of normally
traveled pretty closely together
um but the pandemic was Far kind on on
invercargill with a pretty minimal job
loss um in the Lucario and a slightly
deeper job loss particularly in
Southland which was largely sort of
Tourism related out um out west in terms
of Tiana field and the like
following on from that we expect that um
South and Gore are going to recover a
little bit more strongly out of that
because they're sort of playing catch-up
and growing their tourism jobs back
um as we sort of move out into the um
into the sort of the middle of the
decade now sort of towards that 2034
period we start to see that invercargill
growing it's sort of an increment faster
than Southland than Gore the reason for
that is that we sort of there's a number
of um uh sort of fronts on which the um
the primary sector is being being
regulated
um so we see you know the MPS
freshwater's already already coming into
effect already in effect largely uh and
also the um you know introduction of a
carbon pricing scheme in some shape or
form uh to The primary sector as well so
what they're expected to do um you know
obviously exact form as as TBC but um
you know reduce herd count a little bit
reduce the productivity a little bit
um which has a Fed direct effect in
terms of denting um I guess Direct on
Farm employment but also um you know so
Downstream stuff like meatworks and
dairy works and then sort of further
Downstream stuff which was potentially
in invercargill um you know things like
Tractor Sales accountants all those sort
of things because ultimately everything
is connected in a in a provincial rural
um region like you like yours
but in the cargo we're expecting um
growth around one percent per annum in
terms of jobs um over the 2024 to 2033
period um compared to 0.5 or 124 jobs
across South Bangkok so there's a bit of
a differential there
and and if you look at that Southland
Gore track it's sort of trending towards
zero pretty much straight lining I want
to hit sort of the mid-2030s again
because of a sort of cumulative
pressures on The primary sector
if we focus on
um
rather we say that sort of since 2020 so
um the growth has been led by
construction and health and so some of
that construction I guess has been
scaling up particular projects going on
in the city
um if we look at over that 2024 to 2034
period so looking at the orange bars
um it's a fairly broad-based growth
across on the cargo sort of expected to
come through
um so sort of led by Health which
reflects I guess an aging population and
growing demand education some of that is
um is a growing population some of
that's recovery of International
Education public administration and a
little bit of sort of Tourism related
recovery as well
um the construction manufacturing
sectors are expected to grow
um sort of slightly but they're sort of
more towards the um the the slower end
of the spectrum being sort of relatively
mature Industries um in the region
moving on to our Ty assumptions this is
a key piece piece of the puzzle that
staff asked for to inform um the annual
planned long-term plan
um Ty itself is obviously clearly
significant to the region and we've done
work in the past which is sort of
estimated around 760 jobs directly
employed at the smelter and about a
further 1500 across sort of supplies I
think you know contractors laundry
services that sort of thing right around
the region and all sorts of supplying
Industries so you're looking at nearly 2
300 jobs
um dependent on on on Ty or around about
four percent of the Region's um
employment now 97 of the direct workers
are estimated to come from invercargill
so clearly um you know the effect of
whatever goes there is is will be keenly
felt in the city
um I think it's interesting to reflect
where we've moved from obviously in 2020
we had a um you know I guess the threat
of leaving um at the time and and we
kind of and
um well I wouldn't say it's a threat of
leaving at the moment but you know
coming up to a new negotiation for power
which is fairly existential for the
smelter but the market shifted quite
significantly since then on pretty much
every front
um the labor market is in much better
shape so previously we're talking about
this you know potentially the smell for
closing and in the midst of sort of
recessionary um you know recession as
big as the Great Depression
um that's sort of where we were in 2020
and things are quite different now you
get a much tighter labor market
um and so I think the things will be um
if it were to close the effects would be
far far less pronounced our estimates
that we would take probably about one to
four years um if it just closed abruptly
um for the workers to be absorbed into
the local economy depending on exactly
the skill sets they have and exactly how
those skill sets are absorbed but based
on the way things are at the moment it
probably might be something more like
one to two years just things are running
that hot and those those many of those
skill sets will be in in Keen demand
um in a variety of Industries around the
region
I think if we if we think about the
negotiation particularly in terms of
power supply this time around it's quite
different so aluminum prices were at
about 1500 a ton
um back in 2020 at this sort of low
um they're now sitting um this is this
runs up to early 20 to 22 but we're now
sitting at around two and a half
thousand so the prices are significantly
elevated compared to where they were at
that point um and that makes makes the
facility much more profitable
um there's also been sort of um anxiety
of talk of potential premium for you
know Green aluminum with high Purity
particularly um as sort of um electric
vehicles provide greater demand for
aluminum and so that that's that sort of
Premium emerges that would either profit
have got to leave the plant too on the
electricity side and the wholesale
markets changed dramatically too so the
wholesale Market was probably at a bit
of a low at the last point when they
negotiated two
um and so reportedly the last deal was
worth 35 a megawatt hour if we look at
the Futures Market over the next sort of
five years we're probably looking at
something more like a hundred dollars a
megawatt hour for Baseline demand which
is sort of the um the basket
um that the rear turn tile would be
buying and so um I think the the market
the the balance of power is probably
shifted much more in in the scale in in
the um into the hands of Meridian and
and I guess contact to a lesser extent
um we've seen
um those two companies investing in
alternative demand so sort of supporting
potential green hydrogen development
we'll see an investment in the National
Grid locked in and almost completed to
enable manipura's power to be sent North
and so all in all I think would expect
that price to move up quite
substantially from where it was I think
in terms of picking what the outcome is
I mean I think in in the report we've
tried to be as useful as possible by
sort of outlying outlining what might
happen in each scenario rather than sort
of taking ourselves to a particular
outcome but if I had to pick something
I'd say it's most likely it's going to
stay open and I think what you'll see is
probably most likely an investment in
some more grid flexible demand because
as our national grid moves towards a
higher proportion of Renewables and less
use of lots of guests and coal to fill
to fill the gaps on cold and you know
I'm cold and still nights I think we um
there's much more premium placed on on
energy consumers like Ty that can
consume the electricity in a more
flexible way scaling up and down in
response to um to market conditions
which is you know not possible with the
current technology at the plan
in terms of international student
assumptions this is another area that
staff wanted to understand and to um for
their planning processes
obviously um International students
education hasn't done too well with the
pandemic we've seen a fairly steep
decline in the number of international
students in Southland in 2020 and um
it's you know likely that it's Fallen
further in 2021 as the pre-pandemic
student cohort work through and graduate
and move on
if we look over the past decade it's
pretty clear that the growth of
international students was pretty
closely tied to the growth of
international tourism particularly in
our long-haul markets that reflects that
our International students in the sort
of traditional scenes don't come from
Australia they come generally come from
further afield and the two activities go
hand in hand the marketing in New
Zealand is a destination for tourism and
for Education are generally done
together and they generally cross
cross-pollinate cross-benefit each other
if we look at how we expect
International tourism to recover we're
expecting a fairly local affili's local
we're expecting around 46 recovery by by
June next year and up to 92 by um June
2026.
um reasons for that uh we've got a
higher cost space for um for air travel
we've got much higher fuel costs which
restricts the number of people that can
afford to travel here for educational
for tourism
um and we've also seen another changes
in other parts of the world for example
the um the factors that were in place in
the past decade like a rise in little
class in China it's probably matured
probably less of effective for growth in
the coming decade
that's it the latest um tourism figures
out today um show that we're probably at
about 40 recovery in terms of our
International tourism our long-haul
International tourism already and so
it's possible that we might see a
slightly stronger recovery um of
international tourism
um there's been forecasts and what's
what's been put down in our report to
you
but all in all um what was um what we've
written as an assumption that the um
International tourism or individual
students rather will reach pre-pandemic
Levels by 2028
um so potentially a strong recovery
might bring us back to 2027 but probably
doesn't change that um the bulk of that
story and it's not going to happen
tomorrow it will take time I think
what's a much more significant factor um
is potentially how to picking itself
approaches the international student
Market on the one hand you might think
they're um their sort of fiscal hole
would greatly benefit from having some
sort of international fee paying
students but on the other hand they're
actually um they're operating in a much
more complex environment than the
politics that were they've got mentally
manage expectations of regional skills
leadership groups manage expectations
from National Workforce Development
councils
um and so it's equally possible but um I
guess the focus on International
students might just um sort of Fall by
the wayside as they've just navigated
their way through a brand new and such a
complex environment so many stakeholders
thank you
that's all for our um for our slides so
um open up open up to questions from the
floor
and the good news
I think we opened up the floor for that
doesn't it I mean I mean you did ask uh
the Dismal science economists uh for an
expectation around cost pressures and
similar I mean it's it's not normally
great news there
no and these are particularly unique
times geopolitically ringing just one
question and it really it's probably not
it wasn't required in in your report to
for us down here but what I'm hearing
and it's quite disturbing amongst a lot
of invercargill people
is that if the current government gets
in next year they're leaving
and I've never heard this before ever
and and these people aren't joking uh
they have the means to shift and that's
quite disturbing
um so is that something that that you
guys take into account I mean this is
like I've never heard this talk before
in my life but it's real I did from
Americans two and a half years ago yeah
yeah unfortunately these these sort of
people aren't joking
to kick that part of the conversation
off at least I mean um as as much fun as
the forecast in Gamers we don't try to
uh pick too many of the Electoral
battles uh too quickly and probably more
importantly
um I think two in too much depth around
how that will play out fully across uh
the the country so we haven't modeled
something specific like that
um I I guess uh the point I'm taking
there is that they would likely move not
only away from invercargill but away
from New Zealand rather than moving
somewhere else uh regionally I mean oh
no sorry it was sorry I forgot to point
out that detail leaving New Zealand
sorry yes yeah no that that's fine I I
presumed presumed as much um but I mean
I think that that probably reinforces
what we are seeing is that it is it's
easy uh if you will to leave the the
country at the moment I mean the borders
are open that's true and for new
zealanders it's it's easier to leave and
there are different opportunities across
the world uh what we are seeing at the
moment is that the levels of departures
so far of new zealanders leaving the
country long term uh are back uh to
basically where pre-pandemic levels
already were
um that's the arrivals numbers that
aren't coming in quite as much so I
guess um if you were to see that sort of
trend you'd expect that net migration
flow uh all else being equal to be
slightly uh more depressed for longer
which would uh you know weigh on
population growth but probably more
importantly because it would be likely
more of the working age population as
well it would reinforce the more
challenging trends that mix set out
there in terms of not only population
growth but also a more constrained
employment growth because there just
wouldn't be as many people available to
do all the network
thanks for that it was a difficult
question thanks Brad Tom
the impact of a decision to either keep
open Ty or to close TY means that you
know there's a somewhat binary
you know choice doing here because you
know the impacts are obviously
completely different depending on you
know what that decision is including the
impact on the price of energy price of
electricity in particular so I just
wondered as I looked at your charts
um I mean the ones that are forecasting
for Southland
um you know I don't see two lines of C1
so what is your assumption
um as you draw those with respect to the
smelter or is it an averaging
good question um where you explicitly
decided at the start of this we're going
to assume it stays open
um because ultimately um you're right
it's binary and there's a fairly large
rank between the outcomes and if you
choose an average it represents nothing
in reality
um so we chose we've lead with an
assumption um that Ty stays open and
projected on that basis and um and we've
also I guess our approach to the report
was we've also outlined what the
expected impact would be of two I close
and um and users users can subtract 2
300
um from the forecast track that they
choose to but with a little bit clip um
primarily it'll be clean as a projector
with Ty included and then sort of
secondary um it's probably the slightly
higher probability out of the two
options in our view
so you could have just asked a
supplementary the um I I might to be
honest I'm struggling when you hear you
a little bit some are quite you might
have covered this in your answer
um did you see there that you actually
have modeled both but have presented to
us the model that includes Ty sting and
which I think is more likely than not so
I think if you were choosing one that
would be they don't want to choose but
have you actually modeled the other one
so
um I mean there are the numbers around
that that we as a a council should be
considering if they look completely
different from the the model that you've
the the outcome that you've chosen is
sure
yeah so we've modeled um with Ty staying
open and that's our detailed model which
looks at the whole economy looks at all
the resources and the economy and where
they might go and what industries they
might go to and then as a separate
exercise we've sort of said okay well um
how much how many people work at Ty and
how much does Ty spend and the like and
what's the economic impacts with Ty and
so the two together can give you a rough
indication of you know if Ty closed well
if it supports two 2 300 jobs you're
gonna have 2 300 fewer there's probably
you could do a third exercise which is
specifically modeling all of the
industries fty would have closed and
that's a slightly different exercising
that you consider
um you know you're going to have more
resources available on the economy and
they might flow through different
Industries and it might enable different
Industries to thrive or you know have
cheaper electricity or the like but um
we haven't modeled that one specifically
but broadly I think that um the two
figures in there probably give a a broad
sense of what you need to be aware of
okay thank you
other questions great you have similar
question with respect to the um overseas
students on topokinga what have you
modeled there that
um they will chase an overseas student
and we will get a share of those or
yeah so we're basically it's based on
history and a sense so assumed the same
sort of operating model was in the past
and and based on our um our track of
about
um 100 International visitor arrivals
recovery by 2028 and that flowing
through so yeah if what I want to
discuss around considerations or two
picking or some of those eventual
attitude you'd end up with a lower
education sector employment
just just to extend on that if I may I I
mean that the reason that we've also
gone with those um historical
relationships is because there is a
strong relationship with how uh
International Travelers and and the
International Education uh numbers often
Trend and that makes sense you know
people will uh come here often for uh
travel and they might eventually
consider education after there's sort of
a flow Dynamic that goes with it but
also because you're not you haven't seen
an explicit communique come out from
tepuking are saying that they're not
going to to um look at that Arena uh
with an absence of it of a direct or
explicit um shift we we General modeling
um and forecasting principles say that
we we stick with the status quo unless
uh we're told otherwise and I mean
that's sort of similar with the likes of
t-wise route as well particularly with
the expectation uh that it remains open
uh and because it is at the moment
that's That's the basis that the
modeling is prepared on
thank you
any other questions
if not uh Brad and Nick thank you very
much for your time and your presentation
um and some of the information it had
the other is a I guess a harsh reality
of forecasting and let's see what what
happens because certainly things have
been kind of um
different in the modeling sector over
the past years but we appreciate the
time you've given up and for coming and
joining us early as well do we get a
copy of the slates
they're just sent to you uh yes they've
been seeing Oh they've been sent already
yeah what is the document thank you
councilors uh that can and those that
have joined us on the live stream that
concludes the the workshop oh yeah